[Musique]
ma fille
tous
la fumée
lange
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà assez dur comme ça pour lui
j'imagine
d'abord je voudrais m'excuser parce que
je fais quelque chose de pas bien j'ai
touché à la joue une fille c'est pas
bien je le sais je l'aï expliqué à mes
enfants et je les fais quand même alors
du coup j'ai consulté et le psy m'a
conseillé ce petit bêtement mi saison
qui va m'empêcher de pas mal de corps
les
épis
juste et rieuse m'en voudrais dire aussi
de trucs d'abord je voulais m'excuser
auprès de nolwenn parce que la pauvre
elle est venue défendre un album
formidable on lui parle que de ça et
c'est un peu chiant pour elle et moi qui
suis très sensible à la cause des femmes
battues je sais que la prochaine fois
que je peux faire je prendre la parole
pour parler de ça on va me jeter la
séquence à la gueule donc j'aurai
beaucoup moins de crédits et je voulais
te remercier thierry pour avoir coupé il
ya un mois et demi la séquence avec
monica bellucci quand je rate je le sais
bien que
m'a sauvé la vie
oblige et donc il faut alors pourquoi
pourquoi faut pas toucher des jupes des
filles parce que ça renvoie à une image
extrêmement désagréable et je comprends
les filles qui ont été choqué par ça et
je le ferai plus je peux plus le faire
déjà c'est bien et c'est pas bien voilà
c'est bien tu es cas je suis ravi c'est
le warm up et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu